so Tamra's having a blast and her new
jam yes hear that little jump you just
did so I just walked in um and so what
is this for he looks like a thing one
okay Wow what's the thing occurred
crashes yeah um I don't know who would
wear this like I don't know what this
would be for in real life yeah it looks
like old fashioned jammies yeah yeah I
don't know everybody liked it it little
there's so many buttons yeah there's
quite a few buttons and it's I'm a
little kid okay oh wait little kid
amazing you're right we we're going for
a few outfits and like the backup was
the Alice one backwards again that's
like we did that I didn't want to do
that so we just have that flying around
down the right my legs are really small
you like what defend I was dancing with
the Penguins
my question is fast it reminds me of
like thing one and thing two
yeah okay what are these where did you
get this oh they were just back on sugar
chips yeah
anything I don't know what it is I'm
like travel agents well I was looking
for because sometimes he brings like um
old clothes his wife you know doesn't
wear anymore and I'm just looking
through it's like LC other gyms like Tim
how could she have to dress like an
adult why couldn't she dressed like a
five-year-old or something wrong with
her she's so I'm gonna try and find my
older guy hey this is gonna be my
picture for my facebook picture of the
week what do you want to take one oh
yeah that would be awesome
okay let's see how everyone likes your
voice whether Oh in your uh mr. it miss
the rift hey have fun doing it it's just
some funny
I am super fun oh by the way that was a
nice surprise just going through the
submissions that I'm just seeing you
know science and just we see yeah they
told me that they submitted that and
then I was like oh that's cool and then
they told me that they like spliced like
um like what did they put after my name
it was like a shameless plug or
something yeah that's so much it was
funny
I've definitely you know we got then the
you no consideration for because they
they're they they write really fun
things when I say poor Barbie dude I
mean poor Dora uh baby girl bar we
killed Dora and I feel like Barbie and
I'm like poor Barbie yes that is my bet
this assist award or this is it honey
let's change that modification did I
ever I remember a while it there's like
this big controversy where they grew
Dora up I think they they quote unquote
made her sexy but I don't know I saw the
pictures I think she looked okay I mean
it's like girls like how dare you sex up
door I was like I think she looks
alright I'm usually like of you sure the
first person feeling good but I don't
know it may be a long time ago or
something but I was just like I don't
remember it looking bad hmm
I think she was just a regular clothes
yeah I just remember like a regular
outfit older oh this is something cool
to show okay so there's a scene have you
guys seen Jurassic Park 3 yes oh you saw
the longish leaves like the least
impression on anybody you can see first
one first one so good yeah okay so
there's a scene where whatever like the
velociraptors vocal bone or whatever
they blow into it and they can sound
like a raptor
it's like okay but I say you know okay
that's like I have the vocal bone of
Keanu Reeves I've longed to go like that
so I like about is that it's kind of
like a surfer dude
bouncy yes is it perfect is this amazing
is he little knuckles on the baguette
great where did you get that
I got it Jimmy Jim who made that I know
you're in Jim come on yeah how did you
is this just clay is it Sedona
yes there's a natural ball we're having
to find it I thought it'd be perfect no
it's like a tinfoil core and then I yeah
just used
sculpey and sculpted around the outside
look it's amazing yeah well I I got to
tell you one of these days it's like you
you can do much less yeah I'll put up my
far lights yeah the one day build that's
right weird aura oh yeah yeah I never
hear anyone talk like yeah Dora the
Explorer Dora
oh yeah well I when I was like I didn't
see any Dora stuff I really gotta get
the Barbie whatever I'm like cuz I had
told that you know my god shit is gay
door is a huge oh my god wow that's a
weaker so like I asked the woman over
there and she's like oh yeah no it's on
the way the other side by the toddler
stuff over my god okay yes Borah oh yeah
yeah yeah there was it like you went
like tip it was actually in the wave
that corner along the back wall I almost
like didn't hi We're ashamed we have not
explored if I yeah yeah you have to
exploit she has soft hair that you can
style so I was important thing well why
would you if it doesn't look if it
doesn't have the bangs it's not Dora
that's I'm sorry Dora fishing ah no
we're getting way into Dora this
conversation
I'm adorable talk about Barbie should I
take this out
oh yeah yeah oh yeah she's cute
Dora you taught me Spanish words but I
knew none this moment of gratitude with
Dora understands money forever well
that's I was taking her out of the box
so carefully cuz I was like I think I
returned this they're never gonna need a
Dora ball again you never know now that
I think ya know oh I get the I never
play with a bag the way the head yams
it's like yeah it isn't that interesting
it's like into a Barbie doll oh yeah
it's like just ever that's like can you
see me I can see your cheese that's
gonna be a gift oh okay Hey
quiet on the side guys action hey there
kiddo you like your Dora the explora
doll I sure do well what would you say
if I got you a new Barbie doll instead
oh that's okay I love Dora
no I think you look Barbie oh I'm pretty
sure I love Dora
oh look at that Barbie chill Dora now
you have to love Barbie Dora you won't
care nothing for her you want still love
your Barbie doll I don't want
ah
oh that's insane
um can you get the voice even more you
know a little bit more hi Nikki
you know like that she says to give me
like this
hi I just never knew they did that now
there's like there's all the creepy
things I can do with it if you know how
to do Thai drops the camera loves you
mama loves you I dig here's our master I
do now boys stop that immediately I just
fall like somebody like God why can't as
I deserve boys I'm like shit yeah it's
fun getting into trouble
yeah right don't wake daddy remember
those games ass bro you know what
whenever you do in the privacy of your
ducky I'm talking about those those
those board games you know you don't
remember that game where it's like an
alarm clock in I don't know it's just
Susan such a game does not exist that
you must have mentioned I know it was in
the 90s like don't wake daddy it was a
really obscure yeah it's really weird
oh yeah the more I think about like by
the tie 1990 hit I was already 11 yeah
about two years to play a game like that
messes I know I did yeah I do remember
that was that like supporting kids
didn't want to do that didn't want me
what are they doing in daddy's room yeah
it was a weird board game that's a weird
setup I don't get it I don't
I'm not wait wait wait get back here
we're not done yet
what'd you just say that was a weird
setup of the hallway dad even after you
just viciously beat Tamara dressed in
Long John that makes X and if you guys
no you look at the second target hey if
you don't get that I don't know I got
you that's enough yeah sleep the Bourbon
Oh every time I come over here just as
dirty
what goons fire I guess yes I didn't
write that see Doug took the liberty of
writing now so he's on the seat Tamara
and long johns with the phone I beat her
senses with a Barbie doll oh what's up
in the script didn't say that I ate the
Barbie doll head at one point maybe
boobs in a dream Oh new hyper fangirl
question coming up thanks Adele she said
she is like a hundred yeah she got like
over 200 oh it was like in between 100
and 200 RBZ that's a lie yeah hundred
into weird you keep them all the
questions in a Barbie what anima Barbies
no oh hyper phango questions Oh baby
baby girl what do you do with the beanie
baby I then throw it around or something
no babies are all selected then like
every I know I just feel oh my god when
that came out of Richmond while you're
not clean
nice arm yeah I'm more like set like to
set them up I don't know
run them down with your car's just Doug
was bad he ever to call of duty she says
a machine gun she's lumbar bees coming
up Barbie oh man yeah used to be yes too
soon too soon
I think we've you got through all of
them yeah I think it was a lot of
sleepless no we got through all of them
and how do I grow thousands
Wow I got to go through I've got an
arrow down to 77 yeses in 170 something
maybe so I got a pair down like 200 but
I got all the flat out nose done wow how
was it that's awesome yeah it was like
one run run through and I could just be
like okay these are definitely nose hmm
like you didn't submit anything you just
told me your hobbies
yeah that's enough the people that just
like the camera it's just like hiring
yeah we could use that except for his
name in vain
what's the name general aspects what is
that I don't even remember to be fair
was a bad joke because oh don't you
remember anything about I just remember
the song that's all anybody can die
serving am i right
- alors were like alias or something
landed here in huge these big eggs
shaped like ships Esther they're extra
know that it excuse me of course Palace
Chippendales rescue rangers this was
back during that phase where everything
was kind of a fat monster where the
little kid and I pay wolf a head yeah
why can't this sort of like pet cool
thing that either landed from another
planet or was unearthed out of a box
else was an alien character that landed
here in the LA was just like et you know
et's like that movie I was in
Oh alien boy yeah worth it yes well said
one gave you Reese's Pieces even just
want to tear you there's a poster this
should be a meaning try to eat the cast
you're right she got a nice or up for
this I guess I hope the dinosaur masks
oh yeah that's right oh yeah bring him
back the Raptor yes yes but wait is that
your head what's your head Austin a kid
doesn't mean you gotta like it oh wow
did you bring that with you or is that
here no I brought up with nice I keep it
under like this glass box like the baby
in costume and whenever a signal of a
fedora goes up in the air at night it
rises over yeah oh that theme oh there
it is ah the diovan and yeah I was just
talking about the origin of the mask
this is that she'll be my ex-girlfriends
oh and no I took her brother uh in high
school we knew her for a while in high
school uh he was there is just like hey
denal rub shy about scoff nah
missus but he was just downstairs he's
like turn around for a second like what
he's like just turn around and I turn
around for a second it's like okay turn
back and he just had this mask on it was
just the funniest mask is not because
it's such a good mask it really is uh so
I stole it he just took it like I guess
my now oh I know I'll be much more use
out of this than they will so this is
Robin Hood trope what Robin Hood Robin
Hood yeah you know you
I can make much better use of this you
know in a more oh okay I think cuz rob
is in oh oh and I'm like man is that
yeah whoa whoa it's one of those days
yeah I'm very lucky me
done unless I follow your own goodness
how come is that you yeah it's me I can
only see out the right nostril okay not
me trying to get in there there you go
this isn't dental surgery okay that's
good wish I had a time
yeah you does need a tie yeah yeah no
excellent if you like it yes you make a
great dinosaur Rob make a great dinosaur
is that a crack in my age no good wine
I'll have to save that one look at that
whoa a reptile nonetheless so funny very
nice you look pretty weird to me too
citric noise just imagine how humans
look to us got Pocky really do you know
I'm asking got Pocky
oh no I don't oh that's why you want you
to have Pocky oh the sawdust sticks it's
a it's an it's an ancient Japanese
delicacy
it's chocolate on a stick it is
basically a o or strawberry they had
different flavors oh I know what that is
you dip it in a little no no it's
already know that is some crazy Chinese
Korean Taiwanese knockoff do not trust
that okay you want Pocky yeah so it's on
a plastic stick no it's on a um bread
bread II sort of yeah like a pinkie
stick it up yeah but it comes it's pre
dip oh my god you don't have it yes is
Pocky right in the Box I know ones for
the poor kids Wow a pork hock fancy it
comes pre dick
ah they're the conventions so hopefully
there's some of the conventions I'm sure
somebody will have some it's gonna be a
freaking shame if there's not right
oh there's always Pocky at conventions
yeah make sure everyone has Pocky for us
especially Dinah Rob and Tamra I want
you to give me Pocky hi dinosaur eyes
have a quick question for you um boxers
or briefs
neither I'm a dinosaur wow that's really
good answer the Mormon underwear this is
not like some kind of I don't know I've
heard of it it's like some kind of uh
coming-of-age underwear it's like what
the fuck are you talking no I swear this
ring do you like Mormon underwear yes
I'm coming of age under way it is it's
like you're it's supposed to wear those
like I feel like I want to be able to
read your lips so I can see if I'm like
thinking something or hearing it right
no I think I swear there's like such
thing as like Mormon underwear like they
wear them like thank you Robert area no
no no it's like uh some kind of cloth
it's like that they wear for a lot yeah
underwear
hey but a Mormon where is it so that
makes him Mormon underwear
no no no they wear them like it's for
something ceremonious I got a call the
Poison no I saw no please he's gonna
stop nine-one-one
Mormon underwear talker they're on the
way can you see to put in the address or
anything they know where I am they know
where Mormon underwear stalkers people
like you are cuz there's only one of you
know like spear it's like a greatest
report to the police's manbearpig you
swearing and making it up don't talk
about Mormon underwear I've just set
this up so I can get out of this
like your hat
oh it's a loopy day
it's called caffeine Malcolm oh yeah
Horace maybe they put something in my
smoothie that had no oh that's all sugar
oh yeah mmm
start jittering oh my theory is that my
Raptors name is Julie I think it's a
beautiful name for a Raptor Julie
they're after Julie you're so insecure I
always wanted to be called cherry cherry
also we've gone with Susan she's gonna
be fine you look like a Susan yeah well
thank you yeah it brings out your eyes
I was totally gonna say that yes
seriously brings out your eyes they're
very reptilian yeah mm-hmm
the better to see you with before I
devour you whole I can slice you with no
dry clothes here and here spilling your
intestines Oh
the point is you're alive when they
start to eat you well are you scared yet
is all I can do is intimidate children
where's the door yo my girlfriend wants
me to procreate and I don't so what I do
is I scare having small child he's
scaring me
there is no reason I just wanted to do
in the dinosaur mass cuz it amuses me
you're an asshole
I would dinosaur damn it yeah you're
serious you're fucking serious oh you
want to hope the shock of them all go on
okay so I'm done
gonna be saying I'm just gonna be like
you know pretend like I'm sleeping and
you're gonna do sort of a close up of me
and I'm just gonna slowly wake up and
that just got look like like that and
that's where we're gonna see you is the
dieter clinic so everybody get all this
shit yep
he wants me to do a tracking and chat
with the Damascus that's what's gonna
make it all work even though nobody's
gonna see you it'll help me get more
character that's perfect
Malcolm guesses yeah I can totally get
it it's method actors I hmm
that's just him getting character he
really was okay now go go go go no no no
no mr. n would be stars better if it was
a raptor and horses are horse of course
of course
Yuja letting this play Joe just hey is
that I feel like I'm a kid again yeah I
want to know I want member brownej how
exposed over you say I am tuna
I want tuna it sound like you'd like I'm
The Walrus or something okay I am The
Walrus
okay so that was I am the walrus you
could like do like I am the walrus
story time I met ya it's story time
ya got Pocky try probably a few
different angles with this um alright so
and this is just my say actually just go
critic as I'm doing I'm just gonna try
it from a future
ready and action
critic good try not ready yep and action
critic ready yep actually critic ready
and action
critic it's your face now I don't have
no problem with that yeah forever his
face seriously can you not get it up my
brother's a dinosaur sounds like an 8
he's sick
yeah no I'm a Dilophosaurus everything
you say is venom hey nice catch ninja
skill oh okay quiet on the set
quiet on the set
shut the fuck off also works I'll be in
my trailer
taking it out okay why you gotta say is
just just do about three or four
different critic gadget and action Creek
critic critic critic how's it it's a
such a pretty when is the last time you
wore that hat though there's that yeah
uh do it in the critic returns yeah oh
yeah that's right mmm review not that
long ago
well I am the review must go on yeah you
wore this so cuz you had
Karl after that oh no no that's right
when you were crossing the way you're in
New York yeah it says I'm not going
there yeah
in New York that's right after Blues
Brothers 2000 really oh yeah I believe
they're in downtown Chicago now even
though it's clearly a couple of small
houses in the background Iran oh yeah
Toronto okay snow oh there's Chicago so
I'm gonna ads I get wake up I go wow you
say you know and you sort of turns out
you should be reading something hello
what's maybe the Cthulhu loves me oh
yeah I can finally use that don't love
render of the veils come out to the hood
what's on I'll explain what how I got
this just you know okay so there's an
author at the last convention I went to
it was a really nice really cool guy um
and when you buy one of his books he
says you know and you get a bonus do you
want it child friendly or adult good I'm
like I guess the child friendly it was
some sort of like pulp magazine that was
just like nothing really harsh and it
was just like you know and women
together magazine but they don't do
anything naughty you know that kind of
thing uh-uh
and then I found another book that he
did that looked really cool and I said
oh you know nothing gonna get that
actually it's like well you deserve
another bonus so what do you want them
Chiao freely wonder the adult I'm like I
guess the adult and that's what they
handy it was the Cthulhu sex magazine
and warriors and what's in it like
Cthulhu chorus no and sex oh wow see if
I can find a good representation here
both through sex
yeah there you go Oh see and that's
gonna have to be blocked out okay blur
it's oh it was already blocked out by
believe somewhere
there we go sit down that was a
centerfold yeah see what else we got
here all blocked out by stuff Oh
blocks do have to blur out buttocks also
comes with poetry Oh wonderful
oh how they made her dream is read by
Christine on Muslim Wow interesting name
Brum it's like I don't I don't know if
it's on or Ong um you're I'm gonna just
say it's right by Chris pollone oh my
god this is great
how they made her dream yeah Dallas
render of the veils called out to the
herd the ones before us I don't to watch
her through the portals carved out of
the dark hills the cursed sands of
Aldebaran makes up these names and the
odd angles of the walls these nightmare
gods are not myths
they're made of primal darkness other
than time we get meant festering swollen
appendages dying at relics and molting
fungoides skins tasting the air they
trap the light of the dime universes and
whispered to her in her sleep bristling
tentacles forbidden tongues kind of wave
ever tainted fullness Oh God skewered
her in anal ecstasy oh my goodness
until dawn they probed her and plowed
her oh that's a code through the halls
of time by noon she felt the skeletal
guards such Sarah meets beaten so well I
melted their mouths oh oh are you doing
better in winter but very life what's
your pounding the shit out of me whoa
tenderizing me if you Whittle all for
the sake of the women screw
just such savory meat beaten so well I
melt in their mouths that fly though ah
breathing fast 100 times a millisecond
and his wings giant eating beyond human
sight in which I cannot see yet I smell
the sex of him off both the washer is
the legs back and forth ditching pants
in class and now I'm going more monarch
you don't fucking hisses do the mother
creating rats finds Lala his eyes
breaking hard against me every camera
shouts translated through synapse
telling all it needs to know you know
this is just straight-up reverted I'm
gonna strap something on Tamra's belly
excuse me Oh penny whispers to his mate
who in turn hisses and lips legs
exposing in a sex ready to accept during
their coitus they bicker and bark as
lovers do where we will settle down and
he cleans his wings stoking Oh knowing
all along keeping me in view I am the
caucus in which them maggots will feed
upon this almost cells with the mana
your dumb is it is makes my camera hot
there's got to cool off
are those are those creatures became
different uh possibly but it's the new
diet where you just lose everything in
the middle is the keying diet
the cheesecake is a green screen uh cuz
I want but then when you feed your been
down before done you just bend at the
waist and go down the I don't eat now I
say it's gonna cut to close-up um before
I go too far so you're going to see me a
tree starting to close up here and then
uh open terrific I have to go really
fast or have to shout something else to
connect to yeah I said before you got a
black thread hanging in the very center
yeah it's just a okay attach CD okay
this is it so I'm gonna be lifting it up
yeah correct uh on this one so we can
probably do is we'll try to we'll try
one on action you going to lift it up as
I going that one where you already have
the hands on there and then I get down
and good so and this one you're going to
start why I say actually I will go down
here
ready actually that is this is actually
dad go ahead keep an eye on this one
just make sure my head doesn't quite go
out friend I will do one more lest
anything really dad no no closer to her
okay why don't you when your head goes
bad you'll stay in frame okay
but now the good thing we have this um I
mean this is going to come out about
right here so I mean well alright this
is gonna be the still it's like what's
happening
keeping birth to a restaurant get closer
to her and as she lifts it up you come
back as the head comes out and that will
give you a room okay so how far back can
I go about here ah yeah oh yes right
there okay so about here yeah so that's
things data okay what's your another one
do you okay recording yep and action
damn it that's good try it again
get a little closer to her so you can
really come back I'll go slower okay
right
alright ready yep and action damn it
good okay good
I'll try along with the hands already on
this cool alright still recording yep
and action
yeah so Tamra just uh trolled you with
the Raptor head sister I don't know what
yeah that's sort of the thing I start
wondering like oh no did you do that on
purpose or was that the dinosaurs
planning I wasn't sure so just I'm like
yeah whatever
uh they all a checker real fast you know
if you tick off Doug what it's gonna
insert in the green it's gonna be a
hairy chest
Tim Raptor
Timm Timm Raptor yes yeah and this is
how we make commentary sir we're really
high tech here as you can see ya and I'm
standing here and I didn't even work on
this one I thought I'd come and listen
and learn something hmm
foreign Arlis learns anything here we
just take take your brain cells oh okay
you wanna grab a chair okay Morgan was -
yep it's a few uh I don't grab a chair
there's gotta be a chair
oh there's one really yes this is how we
get chairs this is how we get chairs in
case you didn't know yes
if Nazi cocaine and I guess I'll stop
you